young had this patient who was super
inaccessible hyper rationalist as you
know Carl Young was not rationalist at
all she has a dream of this golden scare
Beetle that is gifted to her this this
necklace beautiful her heart opens up
and it's sort of this Epiphany and she
doesn't know why it represents this in
the dream but she goes to you know
therapy with young and she says I don't
know what this dream means and as she's
saying this he sees a scarab beetle on
the window like takes the scar Beetle
and he gives it to her as a gift that to
me is a causal Loop because she had a
Prem memory of something that that would
happen to her but that pre-memory
required the thing to self- manifest
because it changed her attentional
pattern and his attentional pattern in a
way that caused the thing to actually
happen